so amazon offers to pay college fees of
750 000 frontline u.s workers this is a
guardian story amazon is the latest big
u.s firm to offer education focused
perks to workers after walmart target
and kroger the company which is
investing 1.2 billion dollars in the
scheme by 2025 said it would cover the
cost of college tuition fees and
textbooks for u.s hourly staff after 90
days of employment for as long as they
remain as amazon at amazon amazon is now
the largest job creator in the u.s we
know that investing in free skills
training for our teams can have a huge
impact of hundreds of thousands of
families across the country in may
amazon said it would hire 750 000
workers across its warehouse and
delivery network in us and canada
company hired around 500 000 staff last
year thoughts on this i have an opinion
on this i'm curious to know what you
guys think about this
yeah i think it goes to show exactly
what i was saying before like amazon
you know the the idea uh behind becoming
like a factory worker was it was you
know a good job but it's an entry-level
job it's a job that you move up from and
you know even
the we talked to vanessa who was one of
our producers here that uh the amazon
jobs you know they 17 an hour and then
you go up to 17 25 you work your 12 hour
shifts so if if the idea for them i
don't think that they would out price
their own labor the idea of college or
in theory a college education or higher
education is to make you worth more in
in the job marketplace so amazon's not
going to make itself uh it's its own
employees uh more expensive i think this
goes to show what they think more than
anything what bezos thinks of modern
education where you know he needs more
disciplined employees he needs employees
that are
clocking in clocking out listening
they're being obedient i think that our
modern education system doesn't breed
thinkers and entrepreneurs i think it
breeds factory workers okay and he wants
them to work in the factory you know
well
look
i don't have such a negative
twist on this i think it's impressive
that or whether it's pr whether it's for
the good of society whether they want a
more educated workplace whether they
want them to be obedient whatever it is
the amazons of the world the targets of
the world the walmarts of the world the
krogers of the world
i think they see this is a net positive
for people educating them paying for
their school
they're not graduating with debt
that's that's pretty good yeah um
the question here we kind of brought
this up earlier is this this might
attract talent but will this
keep the talent i know you could take
the reservation but can you hold the
reservation so what's going to happen to
these people they work for them they go
to school
they become you know have get a degree
in whatever economics like
accountability is going to be the
challenge are they going to are they
going to stay with amazon are they going
to stay with walmart what are you going
to do it's a form of accountability so
in the military when they give gi bills
a lot of guys will be like [ __ ] i'm not
going to go to school but
i have to take 12 units for me to get my
1200 a month right and guys would take
the 12 units and never show up but the
military would keep paying the check
because the requirement was the 12 units
not the grades they didn't give a show
what's your grades where they care the
fact that you just showed that you have
12 units so amazon's going to have to
figure out a way to have an
accountability system i don't know what
that's going to look like
i don't know if they're going to require
a gpa passing or using it abusing it so
eventually someone's going to get pissed
and they're not paying much [ __ ]
they're not doing that but in reality
that guy wasn't kind of he was trying to
use it's it's going to end up backfiring
on these guys in the next two years let
me let me go to the next section yeah
here's the second part i think it's a
great idea the fact that they're doing
it awesome that's part of capitalism let
a company be willing to create a social
program for the people rather than
putting it on the taxpayers that don't
need to pay somebody else's problem so
amazon is saying look we'll take care of
the social program amazon becomes a
smaller government that's taking care of
employees check phenomenal job third the
company across the street that hires
warehouse workers he's getting screwed
because he's going to have that tough
conversations with his employees and
they're going to come up to and saying
hey amazon's offering me full full ride
scholarship if i go there and do that a
2.0 gpa no one ever gave me a full ride
scholarship now i can go and say i got a
full ride scholarship from amazon kind
of sounds cool right to be able to say
that if you're willing to give me the
scholarship i'll stick around as well
the guy's like dude i can't get they
just raise the minimum wage to 15 bucks
i can't afford to pay you twenty two
thousand dollars a year for schooling
that means a thirty five thousand dollar
your employee officially become a fifty
seven thousand dollar i can't afford
that i just can't
unless johnny i love you have no idea
how much i love working for you but dude
i'm gonna go get that job at amazon so
elimination of competition at the
highest level all right again capitalism
competitiveness fine
here's what i would do if i was amazon
though there's no way in the world i if
i'm amazon i'm sending my guys to other
universities no way i'm going to start
an amazon university yeah i'm going to
go recruit a thousand professors and
teachers from other universities giving
them 10 bonus on top of what they're
doing maybe a 20 bump if you're getting
80 grand i'm gonna give you 96. if
you're making 60 i'm gonna give you 72.
if you make it a hund i'm gonna give you
120. come to amazon university i would
gradually start recruiting the best
professors away to work for amazon
university that would be the strategy on
what to do then from there it is what it
is because at this point what are you
going to be doing these people are still
going to go out there so the challenge
with that is are you going to be able to
pull universities at all these different
places it's going to be tough because
it's physical it's not like they can
travel to a place to be at the
headquarters dude online university is
that what's gonna so that's the kind of
challenge but i would do my own
university definitely wrong the devil's
in the details too you're right because
maybe this is a military type situation
where you're not getting it done when
you're working at amazon maybe you have
to guarantee amazon eight years to get
them paid off or something maybe it's
like a 10-year if you're with amazon for
10 years they're gonna pay it off i
don't know the details of it but i have
a very very hard hard to believe feeling
like you're right i have like you could
go to pepperdine for 75 000 a year and
uh
you know amazon's going to pay for that
or they're going to have like a
celebrity has to be a system of
accountability go ahead kai pat also one
thing that i was that i was thinking
about was obviously um what's the one
thing that amazon has had a lot of
trouble with the last
times we've mentioned them in the
podcast obviously maintaining people
having them work there long enough and
not burning through people so hi turner
i quickly i quickly looked up what is
the
average tenure for somebody at a
fulfillment center want to make any
guesses hmm one month oh was it that
long how long one year
they were saying that that was that was
it so if you're looking at 90 days
that's what three months of just before
you can even be eligible at that point
it's a competitive advantage of keeping
them staying there longer than a year
because college is what three
three to four years so if you can if
they can bump up that rate then
obviously you're paying pennies for
pennies on the dollar to keep people
working because
uh training someone in the hiring
process is what often costs a lot of
money so if you can avoid that that
money's made up on the back end and
that's another great point kai just made
three to four years college it's really
four to five if you're going full time
now so if you're working full time in
amazon college might take you six seven
years yeah
kyle you might want to turn that off i
don't know if you did or not they're not
letting you go is what you're saying
you're gonna be there for a while i just
don't think jeff bezos is the most
altruistic human being on earth there's
i see an ulterior motive he's better
than stalin though i don't i don't know
stalin was better than him apparently i
i don't i don't know if i even go there
because like let's just say i think he's
so logical that he's like this is going
to cost us a couple billion dollars
screw it we'll write it off and we'll
use it as marketing cost and marketing
and instead of advertising we're going
to use this it's fine we can afford it i
think he's so logical
that uh like even the guy the guy never
got the gift of gab
he comes off after of going to space
comes back and says i just want to thank
all the employees for funding this you
paid for all of this it's like okay if
there's a million different ways to
award it that was definitely the one way
you shouldn't awarded it but it is what
it is but don't forget that speech
writer john it's walmart it's kroger
it's target all these major
warehouse type factory companies that
are employing
ridiculous amounts of americans are
following suit right so there's
something that is i think it's great
what i'm trying to tell you is i think
that's great because anytime capitalists
create social programs
that minim that lowers taxes because the
capitalist is taking the job off of that
and they're doing it themselves if you
left it alone this would have happened
by itself anyways if we had a flat tax
imagine if we had a flat tax okay
flat tax 10 percent
if we had a 10 flat tax we give that to
the government let's just say for
military
and everybody else keeps another 15
what the hell do you think banks would
do with that or these companies would do
that you think they're just going to sit
on the cash no it would be so
competitive that people would be forced
to have universities child care day care
you know all these other actors would be
amazing if there was what happened steve
forbes ran out
but 1996 in america still believe that
government employees politicians
use money better than people in private
business too so it is what it is they
trust politicians with no experience and
business to spend your money better than
the people that actually rent business
that do it on a daily basis
it's it's fascinating
my education reform i did i got me
kicked out of uh a brainstorm meeting
with christy there there was a big
problem with this thing called abbott
districts in new jersey where uh
low-income high-risk uh schools get an
insane amount of money but it's really
just a slush fund it's just like so you
know a general contractor will donate
you know 10 million dollars to a
campaign and then oh well newark shabazz
school needs a new pool it's 30 million
dollars who gets the contract the
contractor right the pool doesn't even
get filled up because there's an
insurance issue there's a giant pool in
newark shabazz that doesn't even work
right it's a long story the average
student in in new jersey when i was
there was like 17 000 a year and abbott
districts uh were like 36 000 per
student and they were like okay let's
brainstorm my ideas like how can we do
education reform you know bring the cost
down but not hurt the students because
the whole point of the avid district was
it was supposed to help these these
students but after like 30 years of
twice the money the graduation rates had
actually dropped in the high-risk areas
trenton camden newark right so they're
going back and forth do this do that and
i literally just said why don't we just
give the money to the kids
if you graduate you get twenty thousand
dollars that's it give give the money
and i got laughed out of the room i was
like what it's a scholarship give it to
them in a scholarship yeah give them if
you're going to spend this money on the
kids give it to them it'll circulate
back in the economy that they won't know
what to do with it i'm like i feel like
the way to incentivize these guys
they're making more money on the show
just so you know i wouldn't do it the
way amazon's doing it my mind wouldn't
be the way they're doing it the way i
would be doing it would be a tier system
here's what my tier system would be you
come back with your grades based on the
gpa that you keep and maintain it will
be a tier system you may make more than
others do i may pay you more
than what your minimum was so if a
person is doing better at a university
with better grades i'm going to pay you
maybe five thousand dollars more per
year than the other person that's not
i'm not going to do it this way you
first get the results then you get the
meritocracy
the money and then you get the results
that's an accountability nightmare like
you just get the money but then you get
the power and then you get the education
when you when you were a kid i'm sure
you guys did it too if you got an a your
dad gave you five bucks if you got a b
your dad gave you one dollar if you got
to see your dad gave you a whoopin so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you